Candice Parker recently served as the
narrator for in the league a film that
looked at women's empowerment around the
NBA available now on Facebook watch and
Candice caught my attention the other
night the players only where you know
they came out at halftime they're
talking about the Celtics and Candice
that they play like they don't like each
other and it stood out and then I said
to Fritzi see if Candice will join us
and kind enough to take some time out
for us Candice good morning how are you
good morning how you doing I'm doing
okay it jumped off the TV when you said
that why did you think the Celtics
played like they didn't like each other
I don't know I just feel like you we've
all been in situations and been a part
of things where you and I'm not a firm
believer that you have to like your
teammate but when you're on the court
when there's usually a lot of pointing
and you know a lot of different faces
and you can look at different benches
within the NBA
and you can see teams that support each
other and it just doesn't seem like that
and then obviously from the recent
comments that have come out from Morris
as well as with Al Horford and obviously
Kyrie you can just tell that you know
they can still get it together but it's
been a rough season so far but what do
you see body language wise bench wise
with the Lakers well you know that's
that's a that's tough when you're going
through a stretch that they have the
amount of injuries that they've had as
well as with just you know obviously the
trade rumors it's always been a tough
season for them but obviously I was a
little taken aback by not just the body
language but just when coach Luke Walton
came out yesterday and said that last
night's game wasn't a must-win situation
mm-hmm I think that that was kind of
misleading and you know it you knew it
was a muscle in last night you know and
so anybody that is a Laker fan or a part
of Laker organization that they had to
they had to get that game and
you know so it's gonna be a tough road
for them going forward but also I'm
wondering about this from a star players
perspective because you've been there
here's LeBron would you want to play
would you want to go into that situation
if you're a free agent that's tough you
know I I know he's focused on this year
and you know the process of this year
but it is fill LeBron James and it is
still somebody that has gotten to the
finals with you know with the heat with
the with Cleveland with team that has
not as much talent he did miss 16 17
games this season so those are all
things that you have to look at I think
it depends on the fit but they're gonna
have to do something through their free
agency or through the truth lessons to
get get him a Batman or get him a lob
and I should say to his daddy yeah I
just don't know if I like I'm looking at
the personalities here it's klay
Thompson going to be interested in that
would Kawhi be interested in that you
know is there somebody else out there
that you go boy Anthony Davis looks like
he has the personality that he would be
okay in that situation where he doesn't
need to be the star and he wants to play
in Los Angeles and play with LeBron but
I just don't know if there's you know a
great inventory of people are gonna want
to go into that circus there Kawhi
talked about that before cadiz not gonna
want to get into that so so like where
are you getting a second tier are you
getting a couple of bees instead of one
a player in the offseason
well klay Thompson is in the absolute
perfect situation for him it doesn't
seem like he would want to leave nor
should he the same I you know I'd say
for Katie obviously up in there about
where he's gonna go but when you're
trying to win a championship and you're
playing with one of the biggest stars
and stuff currently an NBA I don't know
why you would leave a number one place
to you that's just me as a players point
of view but you know I do believe that
they're going to attract
somebody I don't know I'm not I'm not
huge on Kauai going there to play with
LeBron I you know I said something from
the get-go if there was a way for them
to get a Bradley Beal to play with the
Lakers I like his fit I think would be
great I mean I know it's you know
there's a he's under contract and
obviously was John Wall being out I
don't know if they're going to trade him
now but I like that sort of superstar
because if you think about it yes he
went to the NBA Finals and won a
championship with you know with Kyrie
Irving but he just needs pieces around
him where especially at this point his
career he even be able to get to the
paint it will he needs people are gonna
be able to knock down shots and get a
shot for themselves and that's what
Bradley Beal does and I like I really
love his game and think he would be
fantastic with the Lakers yeah a
wonderful shooter this is a team that
doesn't shoot free throws well they
don't shoot threes well and they have
more turnovers than I think all but two
teams there I mean you really got a
other than that we're in great shape
going into next season here we're
talking to Candace Parker who is part of
the players only lounge there on TNT
double-header featuring Rockets Raptors
Celtics at the Warriors back in 2007 you
were named at People Magazine's Most
Beautiful People list do you get a
trophy does certificate you took it way
back to 2007 now are you there if you
don't make the list in 2008 then then
how do you feel if you were beautiful in
2007 were you beautiful in 2008 I don't
that's a thing I started having like
[Laughter]
you're like Milli Vanilli they're your
favorite Pat Summitt story
you know honestly my favorite Pat
Summitt story probably is off the court
we had so many times where she invited
us over the house you know she she was
famous for her jalapeno corn that she's
making her homemade ice cream and so I
remember one day I think was I went over
there and she taught me how you know how
to make the jalapeno corn and showed me
how she did the homemade ice cream so I
think those are the type of memories
that I really love and cherish about
coach and I tell people this and at the
time they thought I was crazy I'd been
saying for years you know if the men's
team would hire Pat Summitt you know
they that would be an upgrade she would
be great she could have coached anybody
I don't know if that's the ultimate
compliment to give her you would know
better but Pat Summitt could coach
it wasn't she could coach women she
could coach and she could have coached
men's basketball Division one I don't
think there would have been any I think
we would have gotten past it right away
because he would have realized she just
as tough as Mike sous-chefs key well I
think it's also the fact that she was
kind of the first of the kind to coach
women like athletes and I grew up in a
household where you know I told her
brothers and my dad told me I could do
anything I wanted to do and to go to the
University of Tennessee in to play for a
coach that treated me as an athlete and
was tough on me and you know obviously
love you and I needed to be loved but
was extremely tough and and you know set
goals and expectations for me that are
higher than I ever thought I could do so
regardless of whether she could coach
men or whatever she coached women as
athletes and it was kind of the first of
the kind of making us realize you know
like we can we don't have to be treated
different like this this is we step on
the court and we want to be basketball
players if you play Charles Barkley
one-on-one wait can you take him can I
take him is that even a question I I
just I just asked em just being
respectful to Barkley
women month month this month I'll be
courteous but come on a question you
could take you could take Berkeley it's
not even a quality path yes I'm asking
yes it's just one on one all we've
always seen no just it's one on one
Candace it's it's make it take yeah like
we're where are we were eating at a
restaurant
no no you're playing hoops one on one
yeah I know I'm trying to help you out
you're really legitimately asking a
question of whether I could take Charles
Bosley I'm like 32 years old and still
playing basketball you know commentating
full-time if I can take him 100k I'm
just I'm trying to be respectful
my my money is on you Candace I was just
I wanted I would help late okay if it's
you again Shaq I mean I just beat him in
shooting last week right I mean you know
we're talking about different positions
yeah but I can outshoot Shaq I know but
I'm saying if we're getting the ball
anybody but if you give me the ball
first yeah could you take Ernie Johnson
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah hey congrats on the success so far
not only basketball but you know doing
this broadcasting stuff it's fun fun
watch and I appreciate it here in your
opinion so good luck with that thank you
I appreciate your time Candace thank you
huh that's Candace Parker tnt NBA TV
analyst I mean I was trying to be fair
to Barkley there you know Candace is
probably as tall as Barkley and a whole
lot better shape there for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience
2:39 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]